in this section we will try to come up
with an algorithmic problem formulation
for genome sequencing problem and at the
first glance looks that this formulation
is very simple the problem is to
reconstruct the genome from reads input
is a collection of streams called reads
an output stream genome reconstructed
from reads does it make sense actually
it makes absolutely no sense and great
mathematician Georg Cantor once said to
ask the right question is harder than to
answer it and the question problem above
doesn't make sense because we don't know
what does it mean to reconstruct the
djinn and it doesn't communicate what it
means
imagine that you enter it into a
million-dollar contract with this
brilliant computer scientist named Alice
to solve the genome sequencing problem
but the only way you can communicate
with her is by passing her single page
of easier problem formulation if she
understand what you want her to do she
will be your best you she will be the
best person to solve this problem
however there are certain rules for
communicating chrysalis your problem may
have multiple correct solutions and
Elise is free to report any of them she
would prefer to report an easy-to-find
solution because she is busy and collect
a million dollar reward and then in this
case even if you have access to this
brilliant computer scientist you
essentially wasted a million dollars it
is important that your problem is
formulated in such a way that any
solution returned by Allah's will is
answer the question that you are really
interested in make sure that you can
check that Ali's solution is correct a
well formulated problem specifies how to
determine whether the output is correct
given the input if it does not how can
you even check that a list solution
makes sense when you write this single
page that you pass to Elise avoid
special terms outside computer science
Elise is not a biologist and she is busy
she has no ability to ask you any
question or to live on anything who knew
about the genome she only knew knows
computer science if you pass ELISA page
with these terms like
polymerase chain reaction she will fall
asleep and your problem won't be solved
if you insist on using special terms in
your input/output you should first
define them as purely mathematical terms
your problem formulation should be
precise
short and elegant if you can shorten
your problem formulation do it the
problem formulation should not get into
the details of data representation for
example instead of number n is the first
line and ends drink in the second line
you can simply write a set of strings if
you are the hints for communicating
Caviezel is no definitions in input and
output all definitions should be stated
before input if a certain variable shows
up in Z put it should be relevant in the
output if you have a gun hanging on this
wall at some point it should fire
problem formulation is independent of
implementations even intractable
problems can still be well formulated an
algorithmic problem formulation is not
an algorithm algorithm in your problem
formulation in the next section we will
try to figure out what it means to
assemble a genome from error variance
but in real life
every read typically have errors and we
will just consider one more problem of
what does it mean to assemble a genome
from error-prone reads and I invited by
informatics graduate students from UCSD
bahar Becca and Nemo ma cherie to
present various problem formulations